Bart is with us in Odessa Texas hey Bart
how are you I'm doing great how are you
better than I deserve
what's up I was just wondering how I
could save up to but to buy a car but my
parents are asking me for money how old
are you 17
you're 17 and your parents are asking
you for money
yes that's weird
yeah usually the other way around though
yeah I know it's because I try to work
hard and stuff but currently my parents
are getting divorced you know yeah I'm
sorry you're out how to get my life
together I'm sorry um why are they
asking you for money do you know not
really every once in a while they asked
me for like 50 to $100 I'm assuming
they're spending it on my brothers but I
don't know holder's your brother he's 16
yeah so your mother and dad not work yes
they do both of them yes okay how long
have they been married I'm gonna say 16
years okay who's asking you for money
mom or dad every once in a while both of
them how much money do you have saved oh
well I been watching your show for about
two months and I currently have saved
150 I'm trying to get 500 mm well I
don't want you be disrespectful to your
parents but I will be the the fact that
they're asking a 17 year old for money
is absolutely ludicrous so it's
completely out of line it's beyond the
pale I mean get your crap together
people seriously the so what would you
do in your shoes I think maybe you can
just say mom dad I'm really not in a
position to help
I don't have it really any money and so
what I will do is if you want to go if
you want you know I would recommend you
start listening to this show called the
Dave Ramsey show and he can help you
he's I've been listening to him and he
knows a lot about money I don't know
anything much I'm 17 and I just I can't
be you know I don't have any money much
and I'm trying to save up for a car here
so no I I really can't do that anymore
and you know you're probably gonna get a
weird reaction might not be a good
reaction because people that were are so
screwed in the head that they would ask
their 17-year old for money might have a
weird reaction if he said no so you know
you may have a negative reaction I don't
know but um
I just want you to be kind and
respectful I don't want you to be smart
I like to them that that doesn't serve
any purpose here but it's kind of crazy
that that they are not kind of crazy
it's completely crazy that they're
asking you for money so but you don't
need to say that I can say that I'm old
and so and I don't care what they think
either so there's part of that that kind
of nerves into the equation so there you
go hey thanks for the call open phones
at Triple Eight eight two five five two
two five I always feel like sometimes
not sometimes I don't always sometimes I
feel like the you remember the scene in
The Wizard of Oz when Dorothy throws the
water on the witch and she's melting and
it's like what a world what a world you
know what a world we live in I mean what
a world that morons I get themselves so
freakin far out of control that they
start milking their 17-year olds bank
account I mean somebody ought to smack
you silly really it's just nuts hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
now
[Music]